et pour en parler en direct avec nous au
mot était à brotherson et les députés
gdr polynésie française merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
une évacuation sanitaire qui s'est bien
déroulée a manifestement il y avait donc
pour but de désengorger les hôpitaux de
tahiti sous pression pouvez vous nous
dire sur place quand étienne de la
situation des établissements
hospitaliers
bien écouté comme l'a indiqué le haut
commissaire même si on observe une
légère décroissance des cas depuis
quelques jours il faut quand même avouer
que le système médical est complètement
saturé et qu'on a effectivement une
partie des patients qui sont qui devait
devrait être le pli en charge pour
d'autres pathologies qui ne peuvent pas
l'être du fait de la saturation des
services par les patients qu'aux vide
alors la polynésie française ans
s'apprête à des confiné en aide ont
satisfait de ce choix est ce qu'il
intervient au bon moment selon vous
absolument pas écoutez ça
c'est à croire qu'on n'a pas tiré les
leçons des
pics précédents à chaque fois on a
confiné trop tard ici on a attendu
d'avoir 100 morts pour le confiner
moi je ne sais quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas alors que c'était demandé
par la plupart des polynésiens ce
confinement est donc là on n'est pas
encore sorti finalement de ce pic du
haut var et en delta qu'on nous annonce
des confinement alors que les premiers
cas de variants me viennent d'arriver en
polynésie
précisément comment va se passer le
déconfinement polynésie française il me
semble que le couvre-feu reste en
vigueur mais que les écoles par exemple
vont ouvrir tout comme les restaurants
c'est bien cela oui à partir de mardi
effectivement il y aura dans
dans une courte période encore le
couvre-feu mais le couvre-feu n'a jamais
démontré son efficacité par rapport au
virus ça c'est une évidence donc ce
n'est pas de maintenir le couvre-feu qui
va
contenir une éventuelle reprise de que
ce soit le variant delta ou un démarrage
des variants mu ce qui devrait être
renforcée ce sont les mesures d'entrer
en polynésie puisque ce varions mu il
n'est pas né ici il est bien arrivé par
avion ça veut dire que les mesures qui
sont en place actuellement ne permettent
pas de
de trier sud de manière suffisamment
efficace les gens qui rentrent en
polynésie vous êtes en faveur de mesures
plus restrictives plus forte
écoutez je crois qu'à un moment donné là
on a dépassé les 600 mans sur une
population de 280 mille habitants c'est
juste énorme donc je crois que les
polynésiens sont plus disposés à
respecter un confinement strict et plus
long
que de subir cette obligation sanitaire
que l'obligation vaccinale qui a été
mise en place depuis quelques semaines
maintenant d'ailleurs au niveau de la
vaccination sans parler des chiffres on
sait que la couverture vaccinale et est
inférieur en polynésie française qu'en
métropole pourquoi finalement le
gouvernement français n'a pas réussi à
convaincre
mais c'est à la fois le gouvernement
français mais c'est surtout le
gouvernement local c'est une
finalement c'est un symptôme évident de
la perte de confiance de la population
voire de la défiance de la population
vis-à-vis de la classe politique
dirigeante actuelle
on aurait mieux fait depuis le début de
cette crise de faire communiquer tout
sauf des politiques parce que c'est ce
que je constate maintenant à chaque fois
que un homme politique de la classe
dirigeante actuelle prend la parole sur
le sujet eh bien il ya systématiquement
une défiance une méfiance voire un rejet
de tout ce qu'il peut préconiser
il ya une manifestation contre
l'obligation vaccinale en selle des
soignants vont entrer en vigueur en
polynésie française le 23 octobre à quel
point cette manifestation at elle été
suivie il nous parle de 2500 personnes
oui je pense qu'ils étaient même un
petit peu plus nombreux que ça
bon c'est toujours les chiffres de la
police et les chiffres des organisateurs
mais ne serait-ce que 2500 encore une
fois à l'échelle de la polynésie et vu
les restrictions sur la circulation et
les rassemblements qui a aujourd'hui
c est non
c'est énorme et je suis un peu triste
que notre président du gouvernement
monsieur edouard fritch n'ait pas pris
la mesure de ce qui se passait et n'ai
pas reçu lui-même
la petite délégation de manifestants qui
demandaient à être entendu
on était à brossard ça nous est députée
gdr de polynésie française merci à vous
d'avoir été en direct avec nous mobilité
france